1563 in the Habsburg Netherlands also
known as the seventeen provinces looks
like this its ruler at this time was a
man could philippe ii the king of spain
who also ruled all of these territories
across europe the seventeen provinces
were very wealthy and so in Philippe's
previous war with France had been taxed
heavily much to the annoyance of
everyone there something that caused
greater conflict was Philippe's
religious policy enacted by Cardinal
Antoine paranoid a Granville Granville
brought with him the Spanish Inquisition
who sought to crack down on the increase
in Protestantism in the south this
particular branch of Protestantism was
Calvinism named after its french leader
Jean Calvin whose views had spread from
Switzerland through France and into the
southern provinces Graham Bell wasn't
well liked by the nobility of the
seventeen provinces who were used to
being able to run their own affairs
after some religious conflicts broke out
a group of nobles demanded that he be
removed which Philippe agreed to the
religious issues persisted as Calvinism
began to grow many nobles argued for
religious tolerance because they
themselves harbored Calvinist beliefs or
simply felt that it was the best way to
ensure peace the most notable of these
Nobles were William of Orange also known
as William the silent the moral the
counter vague Mont and Philippe de
Montmorency the count of horn in 1566
many nobles across the seventeen
provinces came together to agree on a
petition which demanded a halt to the
persecution of Calvinists for the
governor of the Netherlands Margaret of
Parma this petition was backed by
Catholics and Protestants alike since
many felt that the persecutions would
lead to rebellion and also that these
matters were for local Lords and not the
king of Spain Margaret agreed to
temporarily halt the persecutions until
she heard from King Philippe this was
supposed to secure peace but instead it
led to Calvinists openly worshipping
outside of cities in what is called
hedge preaching this upset the Catholics
and so tensions rose and it wasn't long
before violence erupted many of these
hedge preachers who traveled the
countryside attempting to convert people
and giving Protestant sermons denounced
the use of images in the church as
idolatry in the south many of those who
listen to these sermons began to take
action and started destroying images in
churches known as iconoclasm this
violence known as the iconoclastic fury
spread north and the resulting violence
shattered any chance of a lasting peace
a Margaret decided to crush any
dissenters the division saw egmont and
Horne side with a king whereas William
stood against them restoring order was
fairly easy for the well-trained
Catholic forces who were reinforced in
1567 by 10,000 men led by Fernando
Alvarez de Toledo the Duke of Alba Alber
established the Council of Troubles to
restore order
those who had rebelled he had horn and
Egmont arrested and executed for their
earlier proposal of religious toleration
whereas William managed to flee to the
Holy Roman Empire in 1568 William
started a campaign of armed resistance
against the Spanish rulers at the
seventeen provinces thus beginning the
Dutch Revolt in the eighty Years War
William's campaign was fairly
unsuccessful with few notable victories
or losses on land on sea however his
revolt was much more successful he made
great use of privateers known as sea
beggars whom he tasked with raiding
Spanish shipping in the ports along the
coast
Alber who was now the governor of the
Netherlands was not too concerned with
Willem and much more with restoring
Catholicism and increasing tax revenue
for Spain he did this by raising a new
tax the temp any attempt ascent tax on
all transactions which upset literally
everyone particularly the merchant class
in France their own Protestant rebels
could hygge knows were gaining greater
influence in the French Court and Alba
was worried about an invasion as such he
moved his army south leaving some of the
cities in the north completely
undefended the sea beggars who had been
kicked out of English ports by Elizabeth
the first in early 1572 took the ports
of brilliant fleecing him which led to
many of the towns in the province of
Holland declaring themselves for the
rebels the notable exception was
Amsterdam which remained loyal to the
Spanish crown in the Catholic Church the
province of Zeeland also sided with the
rebels whom were now centred at the city
of dordrecht it was here the rebels
Metzen declared william both stadt
holder of holland and the leader of the
rebellion alba counter-attacked in late
1570 to in it was after his troops
retook the city of Nod and hid that they
slaughtered its entire population
the Spanish were successful early on but
their Avance Loden in 1573 a Boers
replaced by Louis the requisites spain's
primary issue here was money
specifically the lack of it spain had
recently declared bankruptcy and sir
requisites couldn't fund his troops and
so their mutant eat sack in the town of
antwerp in what is known as the spanish
fury this turned pretty much everyone
catholic and protestant against the
spanish army records ends died in 1576
achieving little and spanish troops were
still rioting up and down the country
the Spanish soldiers currently setting
fire to everything made everyone in the
seventeen provinces nervous and so they
came to a compromise this compromise
could the pacification of Ghent created
a defensive alliance against the rioting
Spanish soldiers but was not a call for
independence from Spain the next year
William of Orange returned to the
Netherlands and was welcomed as a hero
he wasn't the only one who had made
their way to the seventeen provinces
though John of Austria represents
basement as governor was now there to
John of Battle of Lepanto fame took the
liberty of dying the next year 'm was
succeeded as governor by alejandro f on
SEO the unity bill by the pacification
of ghent was starting to break down
since there was less unruly spanish
troops and religious tensions were
rising again amsterdam had up until this
point remained firmly Catholic but his
ruling council was overthrown by
Calvinists in 1578 across many of the
northern provinces the rights of
Catholics were being whittled away in
Calvinists were ceasing any opportunity
they could to secure religious change by
1579 the Concord had essentially broken
down and two new unions had formed in
the south the union of harass which
declared its loyalty to the Spanish
throne and denounced Protestantism in
the north the union of Utrecht which
wish to end what they considered to be
Spanish despotism and allow for freedom
of conscience the union of Utrecht also
known as the United Provinces whose
capital was Antwerp acted as a single
entity pulling its resources and
creating a common army Willem had also
appealed to the English for help and had
received John Norris in the small
English army to aid them
Norris wasn't particularly successful
but he did take the city of Mechelen
which he promptly sacked in what is
known as the English fury in 1581 at the
hague hear the placate fun filartiga or
the act of abjuration was signed which
declared the United Provinces free an
independent state and Philippe the
second deposed as King William then
invited Francis the Duke of Anjou the
broad for an heir of the French King and
a Catholic to become sovereign of the
Netherlands most of the provinces
basically ignored him because he had no
real power and some refused to
acknowledge him at all like Antwerp and
Shue attempted to take Antwerp by deceit
in 1583 but his men were massacred in
what is known as the French fury and so
he fled to France this wasn't ideal for
William but things would get better for
him the next year by better I mean worse
because he was assassinated by gunshot
how modern so over the previous few
years the war had turned in spain's
favor because Finizio who became the
Duke of Parma in 1585 was a talented
general by 1584 he had recaptured this
territory in the next year he captured
the United Provinces capital of Antwerp
and in the wake of this a hundred
thousand Calvinists fled to the north
this left Amsterdam as the first city of
the United Provinces and the capital of
resistance against Spain in the
immediate aftermath of Williams death
the leadership of the United Provinces
was somewhat troubled Robert Dudley a
close friend of Elizabeth the first took
the position of Governor of the
Netherlands which was basically a
declaration of war against Spain
he had a tendency of interfering in the
affairs of the Dutch which was kind of
why they revolted in the first place
Dudley had two major opponents Maurice
of Nassau William son and Johan Van
Alden Barneveld
by 1587 Dudley had suffered a series of
military defeats in his authority lay in
ruin so he left the United Provinces and
returned to England the problems were
finding a monarch emboldened and
legitimized those calling for an end to
the monarchy as such in 1588 the United
Provinces were declared a confederation
and a republic it was also in this year
that philippe ii launches armada against
Elizabeth of England the next year saw a
Protestant Henry the fourth take the
French throne whom Philippe promptly
intervened against this relieves some of
the pressure on the Dutch who were now
under the leadership of johanna maurice
johann was quick to streamline the
government and improve trade whereas
maurice was crucial in reforming and
professionalizing the dutch army by 1598
the year of philippe the second death
the Duchy retaken this territory the
Dutch Republic wanted to increase its
trade to fund the war and so sent ships
far and wide to find markets across the
Indian Ocean which led to the very
lucrative spice trade in 1602 to reduce
the risk that came with this trade and
to help increase profits Dutch merchants
form the VO see the Dutch East India
Company which would have a monopoly on
trade in the right to wage war and make
treaties furthermore banking reforms and
an efficient system of funding the army
meant that the Republic started to
become much wealthier the Spanish forces
were led by Ambrogio Spinola who like
Maurice was a very capable gem mother
managed to push the Dutch back to here
by 1607
even though Spain had made peace with
France and England by this time the
war's financial burden was starting to
hurt so Spain asked for a truce which
was finalized in 1609 this truce
basically acknowledged the Dutch
Republic's independence and even reopen
trade between it in Spain it's valuable
spice trade combined with its near
dominance of the baltic sea trade meant
that without the financial burdens of
war the dutch became rich very rich this
was aided by the educated and skilled
Calvinists who fled north in the
previous decades bringing valuable trade
and manufacturing expertise with them
with peace established only one major
issue remained religion both Catholics
and Protestants had fought against the
Spanish but Catholics found themselves
quickly sidelined the main religious
division was between the Calvinists and
the remonstrance the remonstrance were
led by old and Parliament and a man
called Hugo Grotius and when anti
remonstrance riots broke out in Holland
they raised troops to crush it this was
seen as a step too far and so Maurice
had them arrested
Bertie's was imprisoned and Oldham
Bonneville was beheaded in 1619 the
truce was only meant to last twelve
years and wasn't renewed meaning war
broke out again in 1621 they soon became
part of the broader 30 Years War and it
ended with Spain finally acknowledging
the Dutch Republic's independence in
1648 for Spain the most powerful states
in the world at this time losing to the
Dutch was a great embarrassment and the
Dutch Revolt is seen by some as the
beginning of its decline for the Dutch
it was only the beginning of their
complicated and often bumpy rise to
prominence a prominence which would
attract many jealous enemies and require
the New Republic to fight continuously
for his independence for many centuries
to come perhaps one of the greatest
legacies of the Dutch Revolt is that a
major European power was now a republic
an idea that would have a profound
effect on the rest of global history I
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching and a special thanks to
James Bissonnette I'm hoping I'm
pronouncing that correctly for
supporting the channel
you